Open source at active inference
institute/journal utilities on GitHub is
a local first front end for the active
inference institute YouTube channel. We
have tables to look through links of
data and now there is a front end where
you can do a variety of things with the
whole channel and with specific videos.
You can look at a video's transcript,
listen to the audio, see it on YouTube,
look at the different playlists
on the channel
and explore from there.
And also use a local LLM chat if you
want with for example here Gemma 3.
What is active inference answer in
nine languages?
And this is the repo.
The
repo is documented in docs.
All the source code is in src modules.
Tests are at top level. data exports of
different kinds,
PDFs for the transcripts,
other formats for the export are in the
data and you can configure
through the
PI project
file
the different dependencies
and some configuration.
There's the transcriptbased.
Definitely room for improvement in terms
of the LLM integration and other
methods.
Just a starting point. So if you're
interested to adapt this, use this to
explore the channel to explore the
topics
or and or
however you want to contribute to the
open source repo.
Looking forward to the next versionings
of this journal utilities.
Thank you.